hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar reducing human errors
in pharmaceutical manufacturing quality
control I am Judy O'Rourke of lab routes
and I'll be moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Bettman culture
life sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex pharmaceutical
quality control testing more than
275,000 Beckman culture systems operate
in both diagnostics and life sciences
laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving compliance and reducing cost
of ownership to learn more about Beckman
Coulter life sciences please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers in patien
just click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Tony Harrison a
leader in the pharmaceutical
manufacturing quality control business
for Beckman Coulter
Tonie healthy convener ship of the ISO
working group revising ISO one four six
nine eight one and two for microbial
control in clean rooms he served as the
UK subject matter expert to the ISO
working group that issued the 2015
revised versions of the ISO one four six
four four one and two documents for
Queen Room classification at the heart
of the aseptic manufacturing chapters of
both the European GMP and the USA cGMP
documents Toni holds a bachelor's degree
in electrical and electronic engineering
and is employed by Beckman Coulter life
sciences is a senior marketing manager
experienced in water system total
organic carbon toc conductivity and
ozone analysis and cleanroom
environmental monitoring as well as
particle characterization Tony has spent
the last 15 years in applied metrology
for the pharmaceutical and healthcare
manufacturing industries prior to that
he worked for companies providing
process control automation solutions for
manufacturing industries tony was joint
editor on the is PE guide to ozone
sanitization of pharmaceutical water
systems and was also chief editor of the
PHS s best practice guide for cleanroom
monitoring
Tony is a well known international
speaker and has provided educational
seminars on TOC liquid particle counting
ozone sanitization for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring worldwide Tony
Harrison will now begin his presentation
thank you very much for that
introduction my name is Tony Harrison
from Beckman Coulter hello to everyone
and welcome to this short presentation
on reducing human error in the
pharmaceutical quality control
Department to help improve data
integrity and also to help reduce costs
today's presentation will be short lasts
approximately 20 minutes plus of course
the question and answer session at the
end this talk takes a look at for common
quality control procedures and how
automation can help improve data
integrity by reducing opportunities for
human error whilst also saving time and
reducing operator costs the for quality
control procedures discussed in this
presentation form a common thread in the
biopharmaceutical manufacturing industry
and are water quality testing cleanroom
routine environmental monitoring testing
viable cell counting and final
injectable drug particulate testing
the first let's take a look at the
effect of human error in pharmaceutical
quality control data integrity
a recent report published by CP HL
highlights the pharmaceutical industry
drive to improve productivity by
improving right first-time quality thus
reducing manufacturing costs
another report states that 79% of all
483 warning letters issued by the USA
FDA in 2016
cited 21 CFR part 11 data integrity
issues whilst Retraining is a common
response to an FDA 483 warning letter
this may not this may be only part of
the solution was the problem simply that
the technicians didn't follow the SOP
correctly was it really that the manual
SOPs are simply not robust enough to
prevent future recurrences of the same
problem any process that automates the
quality control SOP can potentially both
reduce the impact of human error on data
integrity issues and also bring welcome
savings by reducing the time technicians
need to devote to carrying out the SOP
despite encouragement from the FDA in
their 2004 process analytical
technologies initiative many routine
quality control test procedures in the
pharmaceutical industry remain intensely
manual and time-consuming in the spirit
of EFT of the FDA's p80 initiative users
could consider moving from sole reliance
on laboratory based QC testing to using
the online QC instrumentation instead
for example many companies have
validated online water quality testing
instrumentation on their purified water
and water for injection loops but they
continue to rely on time-consuming
operatory water quality instrumentation
for product release testing as long as
the online instruments can be validated
and meet the requirements the
pharmacopoeias it makes sense to at
least reduce the amount of laboratory
testing and to rely on data from the
online instruments instead as the online
instruments are automated they're used
to make the testing more robust by
avoiding human error and thus improving
data and data integrity and at the same
time reducing QC department costs
a study by the industrial biodiversity
more than 20% variability in test
results between 16 experienced QC
technicians performing the same manual
standard operating procedure now clearly
the manual SOP could be improved and the
technicians retrained but such
variability in results suggests that the
manual process itself is just not robust
enough to deliver the required level of
quality control whilst the technical
specifications of similar QC
instrumentation may appear equivalent
when looking to improve quality control
QC teams should be looking at the level
of automation in the instrument to make
UC testing more robust and repeatable
for example a common source of errors in
QC testing is sample preparation an
instrument that automates the sample
preparation process can bring enhanced
reproducibility and robustness to a QC
test
so let's take a look at our first QC
test today quality control testing for
purified water and water for injection
total organic carbon and conductivity
are to the four critical quality
attributes defined for water injection
and purified water in the United States
Pharmacopeia online analyzers such as
the P 8700 from Beckman Coulter can be
hard data to comply fully for both of
these key quality attributes according
to the farmer kapiel requirements
in their guidance the FDL FDL keen to
emphasize the 21 CFR part 11 ruling
applies only to the date historian where
the electronic records are kept the
danger with online instrumentation with
their own local data historian built-in
is that they could attract the full
requirements of the 21 CFR part 11
ruling analyzes such as the pata 700
avoid this issue by allowing the local
data is storing to be disabled thus
ensuring that it does not attract before
21 CFR part 11 requirements as a data
archive for electronic records now
traditionally data from online toc
analyzer is stored in a validated
supervisory control and data acquisition
or starter system or a distributed
control system making process quality
improvements challenging and adding a
further significant amount of change
control requirements to these systems
more modern approaches keep quality
critical data records in a separate
secure archive leaving SCADA and dcs
systems dedicated to process control
only and more agile in support of this p
8700 can be configured to automatically
send PDF electronic records via secure
File Transfer Protocol over Ethernet for
review and batch release thus satisfying
the FDA's Alcoa requirements for
electronic records to be accurate
legible contemporaneously created
original and attributable
unlike laboratory water quality testing
instrumentation which utilize reagents
and require manual configuration for
each and every sample and frequent often
daily calibration the online pee 8700
from Beckman culture requires no
reagents it automates the test protocol
and only requires calibration once every
12 months calibration and system
suitability testing standard operating
procedures are automated requiring no
manual data entry and pass/fail reports
are automatically generated eliminating
manual calculations calibration
standards automatically upload their
certified value lock number and expiry
date to the p80 700 using radio
frequency identification tags electronic
chips are located on the calibration
bottles and these are read by the P 87
automatically using RFID
so okay let's
take a look what can be done to automate
routine cleanroom environmental
monitoring programs now of course the
GMP documents mandate the air quality
conditions for bio pharmaceutical
production in clean rooms but in fact
the real danger is the microbes on the
human body
you've been shared around 30,000 skin
cells per hour all of which are
potential carriers of microbes
unfortunately we do not currently have
technology to detect airborne microbes
real time so air particle counters are
used as a surrogate
discussions between myself and the
environmental monitoring managers at
facilities at right across the world
highlights an increasing trend where the
burden of carrying out environmental
monitoring is moving away from the QC
microbiology team and over to the
production staff for two reasons untold
firstly microbiology staff are
relatively relatively expensive to
employ to carry out such routine tasks
and secondly it reduces the number of
people inside the clean rooms thus
reducing the potential for product
contamination the downside however is
that the production team do not have the
same level of knowledge about routine
environmental monitoring and this is
creating challenges in itself
in larger biopharmaceutical
manufacturing plants that can be teams
at ten to fifteen technicians
whose job it is every month to take
thousands of routine environmental
monitoring samples from the clear rooms
the standard operating procedures are
manual and each sampling location they
have to manually type the location name
into the particle counter before they
start sampling counters have to be
manually configured following written
paper standard operating procedures and
at the end of each day the paper
printouts from each sample location have
to be photocopied because the printers
in each particle counter are thermal
printers and the printouts fade over
time and then finally the results from
every location have to be manually
transferred into electronic format one
by one
in an effort to improve
of data integrity in routine
environmental monitoring programs
Beckmann culture have optimized their
met one particle counting
instrumentation specifically for
pharmaceutical quality control use
building into the instrument design the
capability for pre-configured electronic
standard operating procedures including
the instrument setup and configuration
automatic pass/fail reports to GMP
criteria and generation of 21 CFR part
11 electronic records straight from the
instrument itself the user simply
selects the electronic SOP that's been
pre-configured in the instrument and
hits the start button the instrument
configures itself correctly according to
the SOP it carries out the correct test
and produces the electronic test record
all automatically
if not only improves data integrity but
also could reduce costs the technician
no longer has to take time collating the
paper records and manually transferring
the data into electronic records
additionally by descaling the use of our
particle counters through automated SOPs
this process facilitates moving the
responsibility for cleanroom routine
environmental monitoring from qualified
microbiologists over to the production
staff further reducing costs
so let's move on to take a look how
viable cell counting can be automated in
their 2003 guidance on the
implementation of their 21 CFR part 11
data integrity rule the FDA used the
acronym Alcoa where they define good
data integrity practices creating
records attributable to the technician
carrying out the testing are legible are
created contemporaneously original and
accurate preppy products in the form of
homogeneous cell populations are
typically enumerated for concentration
and viability based on cells ability to
exclude a supervisor dye such as trypan
blue traditionally this is done manually
using a microscope and hemocytometer but
this method can be both time-consuming
and error-prone
originally designed for counting blood
cells the sample volume used in the
hemocytometer method is typically just a
hundred nano liters and very small
errors using this method cause during
sample dilution mixing pipetting and
visual enumeration by the technician can
lead to very large errors in results as
the final count results is multiplied up
to report cell concentrations in viable
counts per milliliter one studied
revealed variances in the reported cell
concentration results between each
member of a team of 16 experienced and
knowledgeable technicians using the
hemocytometer method of up to plus or
minus 20%
so there's the acronym from the FDA
Alcoa attributable eligible
contemporaneously recorded original and
accurate
the USD chapter 1046 indicates that
automated cell counting and viability
instruments can provide a higher degree
of precision and a more reproducible
enumeration these improvements are
optimal as the cell preparation stage is
automated as well thus reducing the
opportunity for technician errors
additionally if the automated cell
counter can use electronic pre
programmed cell counting standard
operation operating procedure libraries
that match the manual SOPs for cell
counting designed by the user the
results are more likely to be accurate
and reproducible as well as improving
the precision and reproducibility
automatic automated cell counters can
reduce the cost of this quality control
test by allowing the technicians to card
other tasks while a counter automates
the preparation and cell counting stages
for each sample counters that can count
from 96-well plates can save significant
technician time hence reducing QC costs
at the same time by automating the cell
counting SOPs the method becomes more
robust creating the electronic record
current incur aeneas li improves data
integrity as the results are
attributable legible contemporaneously
created original and accurate as per the
FDA's Alcoa guidance in their 21 CFR
part 11 documents
finally we come to our fourth test here
let's take a look at the requirements
for particulate testing in that final
injectable drug solution and how these
tests can be made more robust
now although largely harmonized the
requirements for parental drug
particulate testing do vary from country
to country and also from product to
product the volume of the sample to be
analyzed and the format the results are
reported in varies from product to
product for example the sampling
requirements for small volume
therapeutic protein products such as
vaccines is very different to that of a
large volume potential such as an
intravenous drip bag results must be
calculated and expressed in the correct
format for example counts per container
for the small volume vaccine or counts
per mil depending on whether it's a trip
back or not
now whilst general-purpose liquid
particle counting instrumentation can be
used for the testing of particles and
parenteral products Beckman Coulter
Hayek countess have been optimized for
the application due to the wide range of
complexity in the testing the various
compendium tests are built into the
Hayek software and the Hayek will
automatically calculate a pass/fail
result as quality control teams tend to
use their product brand names to
describe the product sample under test
the Hayek particle counters allow the
user to select the required tests for
each sample by selecting the product
name from a drop-down window the correct
compendium test for each product is
automatically configured on the hack and
there are no manual calculations
so I'd like to summarize the key points
of the presentation
whilst the industry focuses on errors
and emissions in 21 CFR part 11
electronic records
the underlying issue is that the
retraining may only be part of the
solution manual SOPs are just not robust
enough to prevent future occurrences of
data errors and emissions quality
control on instrumentation that
automates the quality control SOP can
potentially both reduce the impact of
human error on data integrity and also
bring welcome cost savings by reducing
the time technicians need to devote to
carrying out the SOP
so thank you for your time today
I'd like to take your questions now and
you should all have received an
invitation on your screens to download
the white my white paper on this topic
I'm ready now state your questions thank
you
thank you Tony for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop-down box located on the
far left of your window labeled
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
Tony Harrison will answer as many
questions as time permits let's see the
first question is how can the PA t700
toc analyzer from beckman coulter be
validated to support its use for product
release testing yes good question in
fact in the IC HQ to document the
tripartite committee from the United
States Pharmacopeia European
pharmacopoeia and the Japanese primer
could be it lay down the guidance on how
an analytical method should be validated
to demonstrate that it's suitable for
its intended purpose I have a paper on
validating the P 8,700 TOC analyzer to
IC HQ to send it out to you you
mentioned electronic records in PDF
format are automatically exported from
the P 8,700 TOC analyzer surely PDF
files can be changed so how do you
ensure that the electronic record is
secure it's a very good question and in
fact I'm challenged about that by a lot
of people as I travel around the world
but in fact PDF format is one of the
format's recommended by the FDA
themselves in their 21 CFR part 11
compliance document and their basic
argument is that a PDF file can be
viewed on windows on Android on Apple on
every so many different platforms so the
chances are there's an electronic format
in PDF sorry the no electronic file in
PDF format will still be a
to be read in 10-15 years time no matter
what versions of Windows Microsoft
windows were on so there's two main ways
in which we achieve the integrity of
this firstly the p80 700 uses a secure
File Transfer Protocol which is an
industry standard protocol for sealed
secure data transfer and secondly the
p80 700 automatically applies a randomly
generated password to the PDF file to
prevent it being altered in any way
thank you how does RFID technology
prevent manual data entry and
calculations on the pap 700 well firstly
the the p80 700 has all the standard
operating procedures for calibration
system suitability testing etc they're
all pre-programmed in electronic SOP
format in the p80 700 so when the user
initiates one of these electronic SOPs
the p80 700 automatically reads the
calibration or the system suitability
certified values lock number and the
expiry using rfid tags attached to each
calibration standard bottle as the SOP
is our chronic and automated the p80 700
automatically carries out the SOP and
calculates a pass/fail result based on
the criteria laid out in the
pharmacopoeias now this avoids both
manual data entry and manual
calculations I would like to once again
thank Tony Harrison for his presentation
do you have any final comments no just
to say thank you for everybody for their
time today it well thank you again I'd
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor Beckman Coulter life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through October 2018 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
thank you goodbye